si lindsay graham que es una fiel
simpatizante de donald trump pues dijo
que estaba de acuerdo en citar testigos
ahora hay que esperar a ver si los
republicanos van a citar también más
testigos éste iba a ser el juicio
político más rápido en la historia de
eeuu sin embargo tras la decisión de
yemen racing de citar a este testigo de
pasar por la votación aprobar por
mayoría simple
la citación de este testigo ahora lo que
viene entonces es pues que se va a
volver a votar sobre qué tipo de
información se le va a recurrir a
herrera butler y pues obviamente va a
hacer que el juicio se alargue mucho más
recordemos que el juicio pasado de
donald trump fue de 21 días
este juicio se esperaba que fuera pues
casi que menos de una semana sin embargo
pues vamos a estar entonces la próxima
semana esperando la información de la
testigo que va a venir también
posiblemente a el senado a testificar
posiblemente entonces los republicanos
traigan otro testigo para hacer
contrapeso y esto alarga
de pronto una o dos semanas más el
juicio político y obviamente pues no se
terminaría este fin de semana como pues
todos estábamos esperando estábamos
esperando precisamente que hoy se
hicieran los últimos comentarios y a eso
de las 2 de la tarde empezará la
votación para pues mirar a ver si donald
trump era hallado culpable de
insurrección contra su propio gobierno